avait mal aux veilles et traditions
anton pays on chante my team les femmes
pour garder le corps une peau ferme et
fraîches seront lus dans la rosée du 1er
mai oui tout à fait je vais ça doit le
regardes tu vois ça marche et enfin
marché paraît que bon c'est une vie
coutume charentaises et bah il paraît
que ça raffermit la peau et en y
réfléchissant je me dis que finalement
c'est peut-être le le froid qui a bien
marché et quel est le secret de
questions à l'armée secrète mais ce
qu'ils ont été refaits d'avoir non pas
du tout jamais été réellement non mais
bon ça dépend des épreuves dans la vie
j'en ai plus ou moins parce que c'est
une femme lorsqu'elle prend la pilule
par sa double de volume et c'est alors
qu'est ce que ce pur mais je prends le
message n'est fait car et c est pourquoi
qu'il restait 10 rabot il faut il faut
les aimer c'est comme ça encore et puis
je prends et je n'ai douche à le classer
tous les sur tous les recours à l'epo
ils sont en forme de pomme ou en forme
de poire en passeront en forme de pomme
alors on voit pas bien parce que les
cheveux
ah oui c'est plutôt le crayon ne
soutient pas non pas de modèles
je n'aime pas le test n'est pas encore
mon drapeau et les tétons les voient pas
ils sont comment en mai son petit à
petit son petit puis heureusement parce
que jour sont scindés sent le tabac les
gros et on en sort c'est indécent mais
peut-être que pour un homme sauter aussi
mais pourquoi est ce que tu es sensible
des tétons point très sensible 26 en
petit train to confront quels conseils
tu donnerais aux femmes pour garder de
beauce un soutien-gorge travail et les
bio et ma foi un saint qui tombe c'est
cette alliance appelée trait aux tic et
les autres cadors en laissant tomber
dans un décolleté maintenant avec les
russes et les armatures vous armatis ça
remonte tout s'est passé à bord de nos
pilotes n'ont jamais non c'est bien être
libre la pollution aux boues mais
viennent manger nuit je me balade unis
j'adore sentir le vent sur mon quotidien
le soleil a voulu former bien même si on
peut dire qu'au même moment
ana non je peux toucher voir la fermeté
non
ah ouais